this summer the University of Cambridge
will begin field testing self-healing
concrete that's fueled by bacteria and
NASA would like to explore Jupiter's
moon Europa with a robotic space squid
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow
the worldwide leader and beauty products
has partnered with a company that prints
human skin more Yale announced a
partnership with organelle veau who
specialized in growing skin tissue in a
3d environment growing with 3d
bioprinting allows for the automated
creation of living human tissues that
have the form and function of body
tissues and this process allows for
faster and more accurate testing of
pharmaceutical products
the partnership could someday bring
medical advances including 3d printed
skin grafts vortex bladeless can harvest
wind energy without any blades the
bladeless cones produce energy by
harnessing an aerodynamic effect known
as vorticity which causes the cones to
produce a pattern of spinning vortices
the energy is harvested with a ring of
magnets in an alternator at the base and
if this model is successful it could be
a cheaper and quieter alternative to
traditional wind turbines these are the
first ever images of Pluto smallest
moons captured with the New Horizons
spacecraft pretty moons will is a
personal mobility device that hopes to
replace traditional wheelchairs a wheel
composed of 24 small rollers was
invented for this device to allow for
making small turns it also has
four-wheel drive allowing it to drive
over grass pebbles snow and even clear a
curve you can test drive one if you live
in Japan or California and they're
currently looking for distributors to
sell it worldwide researchers in London
are 3d printing medication in two
different shapes they wanted to see if a
pill shape affected the release of the
drugs and it turns out that a pyramid
dissolves a lot faster than a cylinder
due to the surface area to volume ratio
this could lead to greater precision and
customization when prescribing
medication and also it just kind of
looks cool the Freightliner inspiration
is the first autonomous commercial truck
to operate in the United States it
utilizes radar and a system of cameras
to scan a range of 820 feet the trucks
are saved more fuel efficient and have
greatly reduced blind spots which is a
good thing because they still require a
driver and they currently have two of
these concept trucks built Adrian Smith
and Frederik Larrabee have discovered
that some ants
use their jaws to fling themselves to
safety trap-jaw ant's use their stingers
and they're incredibly quick jaws to
catch prey but it turns out they also
use their jaws to escape from predators
Yahoo scientists have found a missing
link that bridges the gap between the
evolution of single-celled organisms
called prokaryotes - the more complex
ones called eukaryotes by extracting DNA
from the sediment around a hydrothermal
vent the team from Sweden found microbes
that had complex genes typically found
in higher life-forms allowing us to
further track the evolution of complex
life-forms like you and me the herb ding
is an airbag for bicyclists that you
wear around your neck but you knew that
if you saw mind blow 69 at that point it
was just a student thesis but the device
is now available for purchase
ERV ding mind blow complete now go save
some lives kiddo Melo is a Bluetooth
trackpad that you wear on your nail
developed at MIT it can fit on your
thumb and be used to access your
computer while your hands are full or
discreetly control other wearable
technology the team hopes to make the
device even smaller and integrate
different sticker designs
finally the taurus dexterous
telepresence manipulation system is
designed to revolutionize the way humans
operate remote-controlled precision
focused robots these devices precisely
track your hand movements giving you
full control of the robotic arms the
entry-level solution provides hand
tracking and control over the robotic
grasper for our customers looking for
haptic capability we have input devices
offering full haptic feedback meaning
you're actually going to feel the forces
between the robot and its environment
I'm gonna leave you with biotic
butterflies and as always thanks for
watching
you